gleich mal eine korrektur ich fürchte
wir müssen schon diese woche also jetzt
über die spd reden wegen thüringen was
für ein schlimmer ausklang für das
wahljahr 8,2 prozent holt die arme spd
mit ihrem spitzenkandidaten wolfgang
tiefensee 8,2 prozent ma ja jetzt ein
neuer tiefschlag für die alte tante spd
nur eins muss man den sitzen lassen sie
haben sich für ihre wahlparty letzten
sonntag wirklich den perfekten ort
ausgesucht
ja hier bei der spd trifft man sich
heute im café du dich in der engelsburg
ja das café fick dich war leider
ausgebucht
dafür 70
also wirklich wahl debakel im
gründungsland der sozialdemokratie
nichtsdestotrotz hat der muss schon
sagen denn demütigte spitzenkandidaten
noch tröstende worte gefunden
liebe genossinnen und genossen das ist
die botschaft von heute abend
die spd ist stark nicht alle wählerinnen
und wähler haben das noch genau
ihr seid sehr stark nur der doofe wähler
hat es nicht gemerkt hier noch
deprimierender war am sonntag
tatsächlich nur die stimmung im willy
brandt haus in berlin wo die arme malu
dreyer vor sage und schreibe acht
journalisten das ergebnis von thüringen
erklären muss so war da mal warte mal
hatte haut eine abrechnung hier vor 7
vor 7 journalisten es ist so bitter es
ist so bitter gut woran liegts fakt ist
die spd ist in der groko tatsächlich
viel fleißiger als die union aber wenn
man wochenlang erzählt am wichtigsten
ist uns sitzen das klima um dann mit der
cdu ein klima paket zu verabschieden von
dem alle experten sagen das reicht nicht
dann steht man wieder doch da plus
natürlich diese endlose vorsitzenden war
wen interessiert das 23
regionalkonferenzen und ende november
muss die arme basis dann schon wieder
wählen das zieht sich das zieht sich
derartig was die damaligen über über ein
halbes jahr ist aber kein wunder dass
bei dieser urwahl nur etwas mehr als die
hälfte der mitglieder mitgemacht hat es
juckt kein das halbfinale überhaupt
gewonnen
tatsächlich ist es so wir haben die
beiden duos die es geschafft haben in
die stichwahl bei der spd zu kommen das
sind jetzt habe ich natürlich wie immer
die namen vergessen wir so lange
gewartet haben
lassen
musste de nicht merken ich meine der typ
rechts von dir wäre dieser martin schulz
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher
diese wahl überlegen sie mal diese
urwahl der spd war so langweilig nicht
mal die russen haben versucht die zu
manipulieren
das siegerpaar scholz und geiwitz hat
gerade mal 22,6 prozent der stimmen
geholt nur ganz knapp dahinter das duo
borjans esken sind erbärmliche zahlen
wahrscheinlich hätten sogar diese beiden
fi küsse mehr geholt wenn sie angetreten
werden immerhin sagen wir ein
etappensieg für olaf scholz und gute
gelegenheit mal richtig emotionen zu
zeigen wer sich im demokratischen
wettbewerb stellt kann nie vorher wissen
wie das ausgeht muss das risiko eingehen
dass haben clara dazu nicht gemacht und
ich bin deshalb in der tat froh über das
ergebnis und auch sehr glücklich
warum bin ich so fröhlich temperament
braucht man nicht unser vizekanzler der
gerne die spd in der großen würde sein
exaktes gegenteil ist übrigens der
generalsekretär
kennen sie lars klingbeil für mich
persönlich so was wie der lilas laune
wäre der spd was der jeden tag an an
völlig grundlosen optimismus über seinen
ganzen social media kanäle raushaut das
ist irre weiß was kommt mit face time
den mal kurz an wo ein lars ohly hier
morgens lars klein grad im
willy-brandt-haus wir haben gerade die
klausur des spd parteivorstandes
interessant ich hab eine frage um
ziemlich gute beschlüsse heute zur
neuaufstellung der spd das land stellt
keine ganze ist ein dreiviertel jahr
jetzt mit der frage eher können wir die
spd neu positionieren
die mit dem sozialstaat ich drück denn
irgendwas ehrlich das ist mir zu blöd
das wird mir zu blöd ist es ist bestimmt
net ammann der klingen weil aber achten
sie mal darauf dieses ohne punkt und
komma dauer phrasen dreschen das macht
dich wahnsinnig das hat er so drauf wie
kein anderer
hier jetzt nicht im heute-show fanshop
antwort sagen die haben anfang des
jahres ist war von vergiss den
hektischen alltag und komm mal richtig
runter mit dem lars klingbeil
meditations- aufgestellt wird sozusagen
nicht lasst die seele baumeln zu mantras
wie wir haben gerade sitzungswoche wir
haben gerade sitzungswoche werden können
und nicht abstimmen oder ich bin hier im
deutschen bundestag
ich gucke gerade auf zwei handy ich bin
im deutschen bundestag ich gucke gerade
auf zwei handys und das ist noch lange
nicht alles
das ist eine s bahn zurück außen
brandenburg haben und wo das lars
klingbeil meditations- wirklich einfach
mal komplett loslassen
[Applaus]
bestimmt ein guter mann aber diese
straßen gebrechen ist tatsächlich
wahnsinn wie schade dass franziska
giffey jetzt erst diese woche
rehabilitiert wurde als frau doktor
haben sie gelesen wer vielleicht mit ihr
interessanter gewesen die ganze spd
urwahl also wer wird am ende
olaf scholz mit klara geywitz oder
norbert walter borjans mit saskia esken
und auch wenn die finale entscheidung
erst im dezember fällt um die spannung
ins unerträgliche zu steigern haben wir
jetzt schon unter wahlstudio besetzt mit
tina hausten
wie war das zehnte tier ist das
aufregend eurer das große finale
wer muss spd vorsitzender werden vier
prägende persönlichkeiten zeiten das
jetzt untereinander aus wahnsinn ich
meine gut klar
dieses quartett ja die sind ja im
prinzip eine baumreihe also irgendwann
wenn man so lange hinguckt und
verschwinden die quasi für einer person
norbert klara stolz gemacht
ja es ist halt wie es ist oliver die
beliebtesten spd politiker wollten ja
von anfang an nicht mitmachen
und jetzt nimmt man halt die partie noch
übrig sind ja muss man seine ansprüche
runterschrauben wir morgen zum firma
darauf dass cola und und für wen sind
wir jetzt wie sieht das zdf wir sind
streng neutral wir behandeln beide paare
gleich
ja als allerdings sei mir der neutrale
hinweis gestattet wenn die spd ernsthaft
mit olaf schweiz antritt mit mister
weiter so dann ist die parteien meiner
völlig neutralen einschätzung nach
leider offiziell zum du für alles und
kann sich meinetwegen nächste woche
auflösen und das meine ich wirklich
völlig neutral
ja denn es kann nur einen geben norbert
walter borjans nova wo er will schluss
machen mit dem fetisch schwarze null
und er hat als finanzminister von nrw
reihenweise steuerhinterzieher entlarvt
stritten sie sich mal vor so einem von
der kanzlei was dann los wer hier erste
reaktionen
okay das argument
ja es gibt so viel was für ihn spricht
ich bin norbert walter borjans komme aus
köln verstehst du bist einer von uns
alles am rechten fleck ja ja so ein
geiler typ er und saskia wollen
wahrscheinlich raus aus der große frage
ist so ein teufelskerl
wie weiter norbert oder norbert walter
mich auch immer überhaupt zu schlagen
ganz genau wer war der zug keine ahnung
jetzt sind aber nicht mehr ganz im
neutralen bereich oliver ich habe ein
lied geschrieben
playback ab
[Musik]
da in köln einmal an
wie keiner kanzlergarten ich stand mir
irgendwie of nova
[Musik]
danke reicht für weitere videos klickt
unten und abonniert auch unseren channel
alles im kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße